this election
was a fraud just so you understand this
election was a fraud they cheated and
they rigged our presidential election
but we will still win it four days after
the electors met across the country and
made joe biden the president-elect
donald trump was still trying to find a
way to hang on to the presidency so look
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
uh
11
780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the safe i hope mike is
going to do the right thing i hope so
i hope so
[Applause]
president trump summoned the mob
assembled the mob and lit the flame of
this attack
[Music]
[Applause]
january 6 2021 the u.s found itself in
crisis a defeated presidential candidate
and his inner circle refused to accept
the election result and looked for ways
to subvert it and a mob attacked the
capitol right here to try to stop
certification of the vote
now the u.s is reckoning with what
happened and who might be held
accountable
the january 6 committee has been a
carefully orchestrated production
presenting significant testimony and
revelations the committee members say
their findings already reveal a chain of
responsibility leading all the way to
president trump via some very senior
republicans and some very well-known
advisors
we want to dive into the committee's
main findings with the help of two
constitutional law experts but first
this is what the committee set out to
show
that president trump and his inner
circle knew the election was not stolen
that he and his team actively tried to
overturn the election and that the
former president and his team
intentionally incited the attacking of
the capital on january 6th
let's start with point one that
president trump and his closest aides
knew the election was not stolen i told
the president no uncertain terms
that
i did not see evidence of fraud
and you know that would have affected
the outcome of the election you know
particularly after the attorney general
had reached the conclusion
that there wasn't sufficient election
fraud to change the outcome of the
election
when
other people kept suggesting
that
there was
the answer is what is it
where is the evidence he said
we've got lots of theories we just don't
have the evidence corrupt intent may
mean you know that you're doing
something illegal
so first there's the question did he
know that the election was not stolen
and then go ahead to lie about it
but then the period between the
electoral college vote
and january 6th trump took
a
very large number of actions to try to
overturn the results of the election
and remain
illegally in office
and that brings us to the second point
trying to overturn the election
the committee laid out evidence that
president trump and his people had
pressured officials in states like
georgia and even the vice president to
overturn the election
and committee members said he even had
plans to subvert the result well before
january 6th
there were no votes to find that was an
accurate count that had been certified
how did the president respond to that
sir he responded very quickly and said
essentially
that's not what i'm asking you to do
what i'm just asking you to do is just
say it was corrupt and leave the rest to
me and the republican congressman and so
to be clear did you hear the white house
counsel's office say that
um this plan to have alternate electors
meet and cast votes for donald trump in
states that he had lost was not legally
sound yes sir as you can see here this
proposed order directs the secretary of
defense to seize voting machines quote
effective immediately every juncture
lawyers told him
this is illegal or you cannot do that
and so it doesn't matter what his motive
was that doesn't entitle you to
commit crimes
and the final point that president trump
incited the violent storm on the capitol
[Applause]
i overheard the president say something
to the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me to let my
people in they can march the capital
from here so why'd you decide to march
to the capitol
um well basically uh you know the
president
you know got everybody riled up
told everybody head on down so we
basically just following what he said
do you know if you asked anybody
to
reach out to any of those that we just
listed off national guard dod fbi
homeland security secret service mayor
bowser the capitol police about the
situation in the capitol i am not
aware of any of those requests he
understood that there was likely to be
violence
and um is part of the criminal
um charge of incitement
um
the likelihood of violence resulting
right away or in close proximity to the
comments
is one of the constitutional
requirements
important findings but does it matter
most republicans have called these
hearings a witch hunt and political
theater and president trump has said if
he's reelected he would undo any legal
action taken against his people
and if i become president someday if i
decide to do it
i will be looking at them very very
seriously for pardons very very
seriously
that depends on if he's able to run
again his future could depend very much
upon what comes out of these hearings
committee members are already calling on
the justice department to prosecute
people in his inner circle and maybe
even the president himself
and a conviction would stop him from
running again
[Music]
merrick garland the attorney general
will be the one to decide whether to
prosecute and it will be a difficult
decision according to law expert william
c banks there's a question that he has
to confront
uh if he should choose to indict former
president trump
or or someone in his inner circle
what will he be uh perceived
as being partial as being politically
motivated in his decision to seek an
indictment of the former president
united states and the second and perhaps
most important consideration would the
prosecution have a strong enough case
they have to have
evidence that will stand up during
cross-examination and that will prove
criminal charges in our system in the
united states as you know beyond a
reasonable doubt
the criminal standard is really quite
demanding it's not a preponderance of
the evidence it's not more likely than
not it's beyond the reasonable doubt the
committee will submit its final report
soon it will summarize hours upon hours
of testimony and lay out what could be
damning evidence if anyone ever ends up
in court
you